yeah happening to us Josh right now I
hope you don't mind that gave us a ship
name no really
oh I was yeah honestly was not sure what
it meant felt like I finally reached
Wheatley like my three knots like I
didn't get a chance to explain to him
but I thought maybe like you had like
misspelled my name no I just straight up
naval ship it's awesome
we're shipped on Twitter I had no idea I
married Josh Sundquist
yeah I'm not sure if the D is like he
just wrote a book called we should hang
out sometime kind of like the trials and
tribulations of you in the arena of love
yes emphasis on trials and tribulations
it does yes very happy at the end but it
takes a while to get there I didn't have
a girlfriend like my whole life until I
was like 25 and people kept being like
why if you never had a girlfriend like
you seem like a reasonable person you
know like you're not too creepy as far
as we know you're not a serial killer
don't you have a girlfriend you're just
kind of like I don't actually know I'm
curious so I investigated by which I
mean I found people on Facebook that I
dated formally and contacted them or
would like have coffee with them and be
like so why did it not work out with
that and it was a journey of
self-discovery and awkwardness the Hardy
Boys meets like The Bachelor yes well
because this is all based on your trials
and tribulations with love I thought
you're a perfect candidate to answer
everyone else's questions about
relationships because I'm clearly an
expert that's the book has come out yeah
everyone's always like cool so like what
advice would you give to people trying
to I'm like I don't know if you like
understand the concept of the book it's
about how bad I am at dating that said I
went on Twitter and asked you guys what
kind of questions you had about dating
and relationships in prep for
Valentine's Day
so now josh and i as god are going to
answer your questions is ready when is
it okay for the girl to make the first
move
any time always forever is the year 1900
only during lunar eclipses making the
first move is all about being fully
committed to it you can't kind of like
half-ass the first move in
how to recover from a bad pickup line so
is this a question do you think getting
as we just received a bad pickup line I
feel like if you are the one that is
receiving their comply and the only way
to recover is by simulating that you're
in the matrix and if you like used the
pickup line and it was bad again I guess
I would go with like any kind of like
standard like tough crowd what's the
best way to deal with sweaty hands on a
date so you want a date it is inherently
uncomfortable for both parties so you
just have to kind of acknowledge that
how does this person know that the hands
are sweaty I guess the person like
caressing your micros hands it's just
like maybe not just keep your hands out
of the picture I mean I feel like
there's a lot of solutions to this
problem I know you're a big fan of
carrying deodorant yes if it's a
deodorant with an antiperspirant hey
good rub that ahead of time on your
hands
Botox prevents sweat so you could get
Botox injections in your palm that's a
great idea
botulism in your hands everybody wants
that and then it takes all those pesky
lines away yeah I mean you can never
have your palm read yes it's gonna
change your fortunes any advice or
stories on how you know yeah that's a
multi-faceted question yeah that's a lot
of questions all in one question a lot
of people worry like oh like I haven't
kissed anyone yet or I haven't gave to
anyone and I must be the only person
when in fact you are not because I know
because all these people message me and
also I was that person I didn't kiss
anyone I was like 20 for me this is the
moment and here's this sincere answers
I knew that I was in love with and that
was the first month it was it was years
before I was able to articulate that
aloud what's your go-to plan for a day I
always think the best dates are ones
where there's some sort of activity
involved so there's not so much pressure
on just having conversation I feel like
that's the wrong question how does one
acquire a male
this is not like muscle no male is in
human and by acquire trade for sheep
dowry there's a lot of males that need
homes if you go to any like major city
if there's a lot of homeless males
prayer as long as you keep using the
word acquire for your romantic
relationships you're on the right side
how can i acquire love conquest a
relationship I actually did and I'm kind
of making fun of myself died I did you
see used the word acquire I acquired
yeah I know I don't know something about
that I was like I just can't seem to
acquire a girlfriend one time it
literally hit me I was like maybe part
of the problem is that I'm using the
phrase how can i acquire a girl like
maybe acquire just indicates that I have
some sort of problematic view of what a
relationship is I make fun of you but I
empathize with you that said please make
sure that you go get we should hang out
sometime written by Jeff's up with make
sure you guys go over to Josh's channel
because we shot a video that's gonna
over there yeah and it's gonna really
find an interesting and really
life-changing for all of you if this
wasn't like trendy enough I don't know
connotation alertly dating relationship
tips are beginning that might actually
be good advice accidentally oh yeah you
can find out all the information you
want to know about where to get the book
etc we should hang out sometime calm
there's a foreword right but also the
cover paper stock is very nice if you
weren't sure if you were on the fence
yeah there you go
yes so for people who like tactile
experience